avevo 16 anni quando chiese la mia
docente di matematica e fisica cosa
volesse dire einstein con la frase le
masse deforma nello spaziotempo domanda
strana però io all'epoca non avevo la
fidanzata perché le facevo la mia
docente mi rispose con un tono
infastidito adesso sto spiegando poi ne
riparleremo
passarono due anni ma dalla mia docente
nessuna risposta decise quindi di
laurearmi in fisica con una tesi proprio
sulla teoria di einstein
all'epoca neanche aveva ancora trovato
la fidanzata e mi dissi non so cosa farò
nella vita ma una cosa è certa non farò
mai l'insegnante proprio perché
ripensavo all'episodio che aver
raccontato bene oggi sono un insegnante
mi occupo di ricerca didattica e oggi
vorrei parlarvi parlar evidente ma per
me è molto importante che l'educazione
scolastica
ho scelto di fare l'insegnante perché mi
sono chiesto come posso far amare la
matematica e la fisica le mie discipline
a chi incontra normalmente tutti i
giorni come posso se radicare nelle
persone che insegnare noioso che fare
matematiche fare fisica e per pochi e
devi esserci portato ma soprattutto
quale era e quale è la mia idea di
scuola
ho deciso quindi di partire da un
oggetto che avete normalmente anche voi
in tasca c'ero pure io che lo smartphone
anzi aspettate un attimo
io ho fatto una foto
cosa ho fatto ho utilizzato uno dei
degli occhi che ha il nostro smartphone
anche altri occhi
uno di questi appunto si chiama
fotocamera un altro è il sensore
microfono sapete quando una particella
ad alta energia tipo un raggio cosmico
oppure la radiazione emessa da un
elemento radioattivo passa attraverso la
fotocamera queste rilascio un elettrone
che può essere misurato e quindi
studiato
potete quindi dopo che avete siete
usciti da questo teatro andare su una
discarica per esempio e vedere se ci
sono eventuali rifiuti radioattivi
oppure questa notte per esempio rilevare
che possibile co di una supernova una
stretta una stella esplosa centinaia di
anni fa all'interno di uno smartphone vi
è anche un altro sensore che usiamo
normalmente anche questo che il sensore
magnetico lo utilizziamo per trovare la
bussola appunto per trovare la strada
bene a scuola noi lo utilizziamo per
misurare il magnetismo terrestre o
ancora per rilevare possibili oggetti
metallici che sotto il terreno
utilizzando lo smartphone anche diciamo
con un altro occhio possiamo anche
osservare per esempio degli oggetti
all'interno di un terreno eco
trasformarlo in un microscopio un giorno
mentre avevo stavo spiegando in classe
un tema un po particolare che il moto
circolare uniforme un mio alunno mi
presenta questa foto
cosa aveva fatto aveva semplicemente
studiato il moto circolare tutte le
leggi le variabili la velocità
l'accelerazione la forza centrifuga
utilizzando il sensore accelerometro
all'interno del nostro smartphone quello
che di solito utilizziamo per giocare no
e lo ha fatto mettendo e all'interno del
del soggetto preferito da moto
vedete un oggetto del genere in molte
scuole oggi è vietato cioè i ragazzi lo
devono riporre nella tasca lo devono
mettere all'ingresso all'inizio della
lezione ma molti di voi utilizzano lo
smartphone anche per altri scopi
se andate per esempio diciamo durante
nella mia scuola ma in qualsiasi altra
scuola italiana i ragazzi durante la
ricreazione tra un panino e una bibita
usano lo smartphone per giocare per fare
videogiochi allora mi sono detto perché
non facciamo matematica e fisica
utilizzando un videogioco e quindi
conducenti da ogni parte d'italia
abbiamo iniziato a fare un gioco per
farlo fare ai bambini piccoli delle
scuole primarie abbiamo semplicemente
detto loro potete costruire una casa
dovete lottare contro il tempo contro
avete dei soldi a disposizione
e lo fa scegliendo dei materiali che in
base alla loro sostenibilità ambientale
oppure in base all isolamento termico ed
allora abbiamo fatto decine di
videogiochi per la didattica delle
scienze
ad esempio con i miei studenti abbiamo
realizzato abbiamo pensato di parlare
del tempo dell'evoluzione darwiniana e
lo abbiamo fatto realizzando un
videogioco in cui su sette livelli uno
di questi livelli tu sei un pesce che
vive in fondo al mare deve lottare
contro altri pesci deve poter
sopravvivere contro contro a queste
specie deve evolversi per scalare
l'evoluzione e se vi dicessi ancora che
in un mondo virtuale potete fare cosa
che normalmente non potreste fare tipo
per esempio simulare la caduta dagli sci
oppure studiare lo scontro tra due auto
i miei studenti all'interno di un mondo
virtuale possono immaginarsi di essere
galilei oppure newton possono ricreare
dei vari ambienti storici mettendo
trappole oppure insidie e non ho finito
qui mosso dalla curiosità dei miei
studenti
mi sono avvicinato alla robotica
abbiamo quindi realizzato una serra
completamente automatizzata dove le
piante vengono indicate quando serve
il terreno viene concimato e tutto
l'impianto elettrico viene gestito da un
pannello fotovoltaico mobile phone i
videogiochi con i bambini piccoli
abbiamo fatto storia ricostruendo per
esempio la battaglia di maratona e
proprio in questi giorni stiamo
lavorando insieme ai centri di un di per
disabilità sul territorio per realizzare
degli ausili che possono rendere la vita
migliore di sera ancora i miei studenti
con progetti territoriali diventano
formatori fanno educazione e lo fanno
insieme ai giovani imprenditori
lo fanno insieme ai genitori lo fanno
insieme ai meet cioè coloro che non
hanno più voglia di cercare lavoro
perché vedono nelle app nei videogiochi
nella robotica uno strumento per
migliorare il presente di immaginare un
nuovo futuro
vedete nessuno di noi sa cosa faranno i
nostri adolescenti tra 20 anni
però una cosa è certa che si dovranno
imparare a lavorare in team dovranno
imparare a progettare e condividere e
l'utilizzo del digitale a scuola ci
restituisce proprio questa paradigma ci
dice fidati di me
collaboriamo insieme indipentemente se
sei se io sono più bravo di te oppure
meno bravo di te soprattutto possiamo
dare reale possiamo rendere reale quelle
che sono le nostre idee
noi docenti quindi abbiamo il dovere il
dovere di essere degli educatori ed
abbiamo ancora un altro importante
dovere un compito quello di formare
l'uomo l'uomo che viveva all'interno
della società e in essa costruisce
costruirà il suo futuro
credo in un educazione in una scuola in
cui le parti come il territorio le
famiglie i genitori le imprese vivono al
di sopra un tessuto che è una sfera
quindi sono nessuno di essere posto al
centro ma possono collaborare tutti
sinergicamente costruendo appunto questo
tessuto che è l'educazione e
l'apprendimento dove digitale ne è una
trama consapevole ed attiva e la scuola
questa la mia dove non conta solo la
bici dove non è matematica e fisica non
significa fare uno più uno e la scuola
quindi della e lo sviluppo
dell'autonomia della creatività della
fiducia nell'altro della collaborazione
cosa risponderei quindi oggi un mio
studente come dovesse chiedere prof
ma einstein cosa cosa voleva dirci
quella fase con la frase le masse curva
nello spazio tempo
oggi questa questa frase verranno me la
fanno gli studenti a parte che io ho
trovato moglie quindi insomma non le
pongo più queste domande ma ne fanno
anche altre di più strane beh io
risponderei in questo modo come ho
risposto poi realmente rispondo
eccomi costruiamo insieme sbagliamo
insieme collaboriamo io
bellissima la voce di sottofondo sono io
ma soprattutto vaia abbi fiducia
io ne ho più di te e alcune cose io non
lo so
insegnare tu a me
grazie